je vous posais des questions sur pascal
obispo c'est très simple alors vous avez
des petits trucs là c'est rien c'est à
boire si vous répondez mal bien entendu
vous boirez vous inquiétez pas c'est
rien du passé ça tient pas à caracas ali
pour sa première télé pascal n'était pas
encore chanteur que faisait-il et c'est
interviewé dans la rue il témoignait
pour le bicentenaire d'isabelle
morini-bosc ils étaient 1 où il est né
dans une manif dans une manif ils
étaient dans une manif se livrer
mais voilà ça oui ça sent le poisson
quand même oui c'est utile alors je vous
dire c'est très simple c'est du jus de
poissons dinan sont un soir on va tous
gerber ans alors vous inquiétez pas vous
meilleur de rien c'est du foie de morue
s'annonce assez fort
jacques il est pas bien et on préfère
ses yeux c'est pas envie qu'ils perdent
tout
il était mannequin et oui c'est en 86
sur france 3 rennes d'ailleurs fr3
rennes à l'époque il y avait un
reportage sur la nouvelle collection de
mode de hervé le gall à lever debout
ces images
là quand même un petit peu de chic de la
rentrée sera londonienne ou ne sera pas
c'est le pari d'un jeune breton qui veut
lancer à rennes la mode du célèbre
quartier londonien de soro mais bon
c'est tellement différent si je trouve
ça un peu
la preuve aux usa la majuscule s'éclate
vraiment c'est le délire y'a pas de
problème ils ont pas peur enfin demi
mesure risque mans paris j'aime j'aime
bien aussi et des choix qui sont très
intéressants
je
trouve cette collection magnifique
surtout très beau temps est magnifique
pascal elle tend à passer non tu es
toujours beaux arts est non mais je vais
te dire les cheveux aujourd'hui sert
plus à rien mais je te le dis toi ça te
va très bien comme ça toi tu as la
chance et il à la chaux-de-fonds est bel
et bien comme ça et d'avoir un bon bah
oui merci en tout cas très belle un flou
et apporte une importante vous
travaillez pour crâne point c'est
votre pourtant à bordeaux devant des
gens comme ça qui sahara qui savent
rebondir que tu es tout ça tenait de la
faute et les spectacles
alors merci rien c'est là mes fans non
c'est la merde et sheeran
question pour vous tiens je demande à
bernard montiel bien qui sait tout sur
tout à part sur lui-même france gall a
refusé plusieurs chansons de pascal qui
ont pourtant été des tubes par la suite
parmi ses chansons avait eu the end de
zazie tu trouveras de natasha st-pier
seul de garou ou la moule à gâteau
c'est tu trouveras ouais tu tries y aura
hélas mais trouva elle a refusé mais
j'ai la chance de recevoir pascal sur
rfm donc je serai au cou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette cure japonais
mes mots
mais obama
et de l'amour président oh
j'aime encore
je suis gentil
c'est beaucoup
tu
alors
j'adore quand aujourd'hui par une limite
tout le temps tous les maux de la france
m mais je rentre en lui
par son team
c'est le boulot d'un compositeur de se
mettre au service d'un nom mais c'est ça
ma lèvre d'un style et c'est vrai à
l'époque j'avais fabriqué enfin j'avais
on avait conçu et mon camarade lionel
florence urnes avait conçu une douzaine
de chansons et pour essayer de la
séduire mon tout en sachant que elle
avait déjà arrêté mais la personne qui
m'avait un petit peu proposer cette
histoire a un petit peu insisté donc on
a eu un rendez vous effectivement j'ai
rencontré france on était chez elle et
puis après le dîner j'ai été chanté ses
chansons sur le piano de michel berger
et elle m'a dit cette phrase qui restera
en fait dans mon coeur tout le temps
c'est oui c'est michel mais c'est pas
michel c'est à dire oui j'ai bien bossé
en tant que compositeur mais elle
déclare un amour absolu à son homme et
sur sa magnifique voix prenez-en de la
graine
je suis reparti avec ses chansons et
puis tu vois en faisant cette
application obispo l'access jets ont
fait des expériences et j'ai un peu
comme un essayiste tu vois c'est un
petit peu comme toi on essaye des choses
à voir j'ai essayé de nous reproduire
sont un peu comme ça comme si on était
dans les années 80 et en reprenant donc
toutes ces chansons que j'avais écrit
pour tous dit attendu deux envols de
sortir 24 ans maintenant c'est bien
l'air de rien il ment quelqu'un
c'est rien toqué prochain
[Applaudissements]
c'est combien de 3 est attendu avant de
sortir 24 euros
je sais qu'à des animateurs qui 6 2 au
4 août attendu mais c'est toujours
autant les émissions ce que je dois
écouter pas vous allez toujours autant
bossé
c'est vraiment aujourd'hui j'ai envie
t'inquiète pas je le savais c'est juste
voilà
qui ne l'a pas fait
donc pourquoi 24 ans pourquoi 24 ans
pourquoi 24 et parce que les dix juste
avant que j'étais un peu et cic avec mon
habit de satin
en fait on fait des expériences on a
déjà fait plusieurs expériences sur une
quinzaine d'albums parce que j'ai des
milliers d'abonnés et tous les vendredis
je leur propose de nouvelles chansons
donc j'essaie des choses et j'ai
retrouvé dans mon ordinateur
les versions originales de toutes ses
chansons j'ai eu envie de les refaire
pour m'amuser on m'a dit tu devrais le
sortir en physique parce que pour moi le
physique c'est aussi important moi j'ai
travaillé la fnac oui je sais rien tu
venais voir la fin et justement
d'ailleurs je l'avais vu à la fnac et
c'est vrai que tu me voyais tout le
temps la fin j'étais tout le temps là
faudrait chercher quoi glaxo il est
supérieur
il est avec son téléphone ouais et
tourner autour des cendres le voyait
juger mais j
ai parlé à des gens je pense qu'il était
en train de construire sa carrière déjà
j'ai construit
et je remercie tous les tous les tous
les disquaires passer des disques voilà
c'est fini et c'est super important
voilà alors avant de vendre des millions
de disques pascal a été vendeur de
fruits et légumes vendeur du disque de
bernard montiel absolue dément foule
vendeurs de postiches ou vendeurs
d'huîtres dans le bassin d'arcachon a
fait un disque de toi c'est pour jean
michel maire pour vient d'avoir la
réponse vendeurs de disques tarnac
c'est pas très bonnes réponses
aujourd'hui
je n'ai jamais vu dans mes rayons à
l'écouté
[Musique]
[Rires]
les baux se serait passé
j'entends ça je me dis vous êtes bon
dans tout ce que vous faites honnêtement
c'est fou mais c'est
aussi quelqu'un d'autre ça pourrait
fonctionner
quelqu'un d'autre c'est normal c'était
une chanson un peu de non c'est pas ça
laisse enfin l'époque julio iglesias
genre période sous le soleil honneur
donc s'ils descendent et d'ailleurs j'ai
fait un titre aussi pour le la bande
originale de sous le soleil avait en
espagnol je les ai écrites mais ça fait
comment nommer qu en salle et sa vie des
civils qui étaient calmés quand il
n'a pas dit non mais je te dirai pas
tant attendu de sa
part égale alors vous savez quoi oui non
et amélie belle époque tf1 sous le
soleil 80000 un truc comme ça sur les
sous
[Rires]
sabathé crime par
sébastien quel immense animateur télé
pascal obispo n'at-il pas reconnu en
direct michel drucker jean-pierre
foucault matthieu delormeau patrick
sébastien je
tiens à tchatcher de leurs maux la bonne
réponse est c'est vrai qu'on leur
connaît
sera de retour demain actuellement il
est en tournée pour son nouvel album je
n'ai plus de travail
et wade mais le 18 les mathieu parler et
parler avec pascal lalle images et bien
sûr qu on a l'image franchement je suis
allé au monde vous a pas laissé des
souvenirs impérissables
c'est la première fois que vous le voyez
en vrai non non
on a tant fait deux échéances lance me
souviens très bien des missions c'était
le spécial céline dion casser la baraque
aussi oui je suis
témoin
ferrer un présentateur tabassian
tentateur étaient sur le bateau oui tout
à fait mais quand ça va mal et servait
des souris
[Rires]
je me souviens très bien de lui la
première fois que j'ai vu à huy est
presque gênant basescu tout comme gênant
parce qu'en fait il avait dit à mon
attachée de presse ils croyaient que je
l'avais draguer etc non sérieusement à
me croit souvent il fait ça tout le
monde problème
il est très gentil gars un gentil garçon
il sera avec nous demain bien sûr on
mathieu et vous n'êtes jamais tomber
pour lui
quel point commun aux passants ouais
mais quel point comment pascal obispo et
benjamin castaldi question pour isabelle
morini bosc ils ont tous les deux fait
une augmentation mammaire
ils ont tous les deux cet enfant mais
dont sept enfants dont trois d'un
déclaré ils ont tous les deux chanter la
reine des neiges en bitume où ils ont
tous les deux été élu troisième
animateur de séville à
la reine des gens que je suis né
c'est impossible
c'est toi qui viens de répondre oui oui
c'est moi tu dois faire pendre c'est
bien beau isabelle moret
c'est ton crétine toutes les câbles non
non non et non celles ci jouent tous les
deux étaient d'accord il peut
lever sa tête vous réveiller
c'est monsieur monsieur là
il m'a dit je vais penser j'ai pas dit
parce que c'était lors du concert ce qui
fait en dix ans de carrière de michael
gregorio tu avais fait une apparition
remarquée
examen et j'espère qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'un cadre
bâti
libéré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout le
royaume de solitude
luc ma place tient toujours
je vends rien
[Musique]
demain
[Applaudissements]
mes chansons préférées pascal en tout
cas au niveau vocal ya quand même hein
l'émission de bruno formidable j'ai au
moins c'est un plaisir à michael bay
monde adore mes manies voulait m'inviter
centre me moque un peu de toi et ses
terrains et c'est génial de rentrer pour
la reine des neiges jeudi mais c'est
tout alors nous pousse à confusion je
vais rentrer en reine des neiges mais
c'est vrai que bon depuis je suis
influenceurs ouais c'est vrai moi c'est
moi qui vous accuse c'est vrai c'est
qu'un curseur là
mais c'est quand même franchi un niveau
bien il ya stadiste n'a pas porté
plainte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]